for those undecided it was a chance to
challenge the leadership hopefuls face
to face
i really want to hear how they're going
to tackle some of the key issues that
are important for me they both have
strong points either side i'm not yet
convinced on who will be the right
person
you can read body language so you have
an opportunity to see the instant
reaction to the question
many have traveled hundreds of miles to
be here
looking forward to seeing what their
responses are and i hope they don't
dodge the question
retired retail manager claire greenfield
is from solihull if you become pm will
you commit to increasing the size and
budget of our armed forces to make this
country once again a force to be
reckoned with
yes claire that the simple answer is
absolutely and i don't want to say once
again because i think we are already a
force to be reckoned with so what i can
commit to claire is this i will tell you
i will invest whatever it takes to keep
you and everyone else in our country
safe
how important is it to balance the books
it isn't right to try and balance the
book straight away when we've had a
major global crisis like covid and every
single country in the world has built up
debts from that crisis sulumbi is a
conservative councillor from harrogate
thank you you were also the chancellor
that introduced eat out to dine out
at a cost of 850 million pounds and
according to the university of warwick
that was responsible for an increase of
nuclear cases of between 8 and 17
well actually that's one study that said
that and i don't think it's right we had
hundreds of thousands of largely small
hospitality businesses that were on the
brink of bankruptcy because in this
country everyone was so scared and all
the evidence said that no one was going
to go back out again and in an economy
like ours that would have been
disastrous the battle for number 10 has
reached a crucial stage ballot papers
are on the way and voting is due to
begin the audience here pressed the
candidates on the big issues the nhs the
cost of living world events but did they
manage to persuade those undecided
members of the audience i think i'm
going to go with liz truss
i think richie did a pretty good debate
i came here intending to vote for liz
trust
barring anything major and nothing
happened to dissuade me i'm very
confident in my vocabularies trust i
think i'd be very used to that his
answers
at some point when he was asked to be
short was short he was clear he was
concise claire su and pratyus are among
the 160 000 conservative members who
have a huge decision to make one that
will dictate a new direction for britain
nick martin sky news